be yourself
they're gonna love you i hate
so much about the things that you choose
to be
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
the guy who loves flag smashing and this
video we're giving our thoughts on some
of the most hotly debated talking points
in regards to falcon in the winter
soldier
if you're like me and don't have a life
which you probably don't because you're
watching this video then chances are
you've come across
a big argument on twitter involving john
walker
and also io of the dora melange full
spoilers ahead from this point out so if
you haven't had a chance to check out
the latest episode of falcon in the
winter soldier then i highly recommend
that you check out now
if you agree with our points then make
sure you hit the thumbs up button
and if you don't then the dislike is
there for you too without out the way
thank you for clicking this
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
the first talking point came from
whether john walker was right in killing
the flag smasher
for some context the scene culminated in
jeon killing the antagonist in front of
the public
after his best bud battle star had been
brutally murdered
by having his back broken in the comics
it was actually walker's parents that
were killed
and this sent him off the deep end
leading to him becoming a terrifying
vigilante that acted without
jurisdiction or a moral code
whilst we don't know his eventual arc
just yet it seems like they're setting
up the show for something similar
and we will likely watch him on a
downward spiral requiring sam to take
him down
now john flickinger basically started
the debate by having the bloody gaul
the bloody goal of that man to tweet the
following
knockoff captain america has now become
my favorite character in hashtag falcon
in the winter soldier
a man willing to do what it takes
america thanks you for your service
though i don't know him on a personal
level i have watched his channel for a
number of years which is why i got the
accent spot on
and i don't think he's someone who
thinks it's cool to go around murdering
people i just don't get that impression
of him
though he's been called a psycho john
even cleared up that the tweet was
sarcastic
but because it's the internet where
everyone reads text in a different way
there were a lot of different opinions
that came forward because of it
at the moment the discord seems to be
split into two sides with one condemning
walker
whilst the others praise him for taking
down a terrorist
now personally i am against what walker
did and i'll explain why
in my opinion though the flag smasher
has clearly been carrying out terrorist
acts
captain america isn't someone who should
be killing people who've already
surrendered
in the scene we watch as the man begs
for his life and it would be nothing for
walker to take him alive at this point
though he's a super soldier walker is
too and he's already shown because of
the military training that he's received
with the formula he easily outmatches
all the other flag smashes
the shield is supposed to be a symbol of
truth justice
and the american way and to see it
covered in blood like this
shows just how much the legacy has been
tarnished a shield is an item that's
supposed to be used for defense but here
it's almost a battering ram
being used in an offensive manner to end
someone's life
what walker represented to me in that
scene was police brutality
and though he should have stayed his
hand he instead went over the top to
kill someone
this was a personal vendetta because of
the death of his friend
and rather than doing his duty he made
it his mission to get revenge
rather than justice mark bernardin has
stated that steve rogers is what america
thinks it is
whereas john walker is what it truly is
it's a saying that's often been
attributed to superman and batman
but in the case of the two caps it
actually feels far more fitting
now being a brit i don't want to wade in
slagging a whole country that i love off
but i'm sure most people watching this
will be willing to admit that the
western world has a complicated legacy
much like the shield itself britain's
just as bad and whether we want to admit
it or not
there's been a lot of things in our past
that we aren't really proud of
and walker 2 represents that to me
though he's operating as the symbol of
idealism and freedom
it's clear that he's far more
complicated than that and he's way more
flawed than steve rogers ever was
now to me this is actually a more
accurate representation of what someone
put in this position would be like
and you can see how someone who's been
told that they can basically do what
they want
would do exactly that so no personally i
don't think that walker was in the right
and if he truly was captain america then
he would have taken this man in
when i've discussed this the first thing
brought up normally is that his friend
had just died
however steve believed that his friend
bucky was dead for several years too
and he never acted out of character or
lost his cool because of it
therefore in regards to this i still
think that walker is the villain
rather than a hero who was simply
carrying out something for the greater
good
and that takes us to io and the dora
melange
the first point of contention that has
caused a lot of heated debates
is that they state they have
jurisdiction wherever they choose to
have it
whether this is official or not we don't
know but there's also
no way to know what's happened with
wakanda since they joined the un
because they're a technologically
advanced society it is possible that
their police force is able to operate
wherever they want to
but i also highly doubt it to me it was
just a badass line to assert dominance
and though it contradicts the sokovia
records i didn't really ding the show
for her coming out with it
mirroring this line walker has two said
he operates without jurisdiction outside
of the us
which no one has been up in arms about
at all it could be that since the world
destabilized due to the snap in the blip
that the authorities have extra powers
when it comes to how and where they
operate
or it could just be a cool line because
yeah this this stuff is all made up
anyway
steven ford discussed another moment
featuring the character
and this too has caused a heated debate
with every marvel maniac
the original tweet reads okay but there
were cannons putting a belt in weakness
in bucky's
arm is like really messed up it shows
they never fully trusted him
he spent years trying to finally reclaim
his autonomy only to be undermined in an
instant by those who helped
it's just sad now personally i didn't
even really pick up on this whilst
watching it
and again just thought it was a cool
moment but i've seen so much back and
forth over at recording race and so on
that
it definitely feels like there's a lot
of subtext to be taken from it
now i'm someone who grew up reading
stories like jla the tower of babel
in which it's revealed that batman has
several contingencies for the justice
league
so the idea that you always have a
backup plan even when it's your friend
is nothing new to me i can totally see
why the wakandans did this
and if you think about bucky's life he's
spent the last 80 years being a
brainwashed murderer
after that he's one of the last
surviving super soldiers who's fluent in
several languages
and an expert in hand-to-hand combat and
weapons and yet
you can see why they might put some
counter-measures in place
the scene itself also comes in the wake
of io telling bucky that he had a time
limit to hand zemo over
bucky very much betrayed them by freeing
the person that killed their king and
they gave him the chance to do the job
that they needed to
before taking him in instead bucky stood
in their way and tried to stop them
and thus i think io did what she had to
in disarming him
and i swear that's not a pun now
christine kippins recently got asked
about this
and she gave an answer about how both
bucky's arm and the shield come from
wakanda
but we never really classed the ladder
as that let's play the clip so you can
hear
play play the press play quickly bucky
doesn't think of that
arm as a piece of wakandan technology
that was given to him so that he could
be helpful in an
upcoming fight for global survival and
walker doesn't think of that shield
as coming from wakanda either bucky
thinks of that arm
as his arm as part of him
and walker thinks of that shield as his
weapon that he has done the work
for and has earned to carry and when the
dora
took them both away for just a moment
just a moment they each had terrible
fear in their eyes and bucky even had
the nerve to look
betrayed the dorm melanche are here to
remind you all of your white privilege
and the fact that what makes america
strong
was stolen from black indigenous and
people of color
okay so lots to take from that and i
think as far as the wakundens go
they did what they could to help and
rehabilitate bucky
however they also kept in the back of
their minds that because of his powers
and abilities
that he might cause issues for them one
day though bucky believes he was
betrayed because of this
it's understandable that they built this
failed safe in
in this moment when buggy fails to keep
his word the dora melange disarm him
and show that they have their means of
fighting dirty too
had bucky not betrayed them then we
would never have known about this
failsafe
and he could have carried on living his
best life with his mechanical arm you
know
i could use a mechanical arm a lot
especially in lockdown
although i know a lot of people probably
disagree with this i can personally see
why the action was taken
and from their point of view i think
that they were in the right
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts so make sure you comment below
and let me know
remember yeah this is all fictional john
walker and wakanda don't exist
so keep it civil instead of turning
things into a civil
war as a thank you for interacting
civilly with the video
you'll be entered into a prize during
the 30th of april in which we're giving
away three copies of zack snyder's
justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the video the winners of
last month's competition are on screen
right now so if that's you then message
me on twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want somebody else to watch them
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the episode 5 cameo which will be linked
on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
by the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul and i
see you next time
take care peace
you